Oh
you
so there's a great essay written by
Sigmund Freud called on transience and
in it he cites a conversation that he
had with the poet Rilke II as they were
walking along this beautiful garden and
at one point really looked like he was
about to tear up and Freud said what's
wrong it's a beautiful day there's
beautiful plants around us this is
magnificent and then Ricky says well I
can't get over the fact that one day all
of this is going to die all these trees
all these plants all this life is going
to decay everything dissolves in
meaninglessness when you think about the
fact that impermanence is really real
thing perhaps the greatest existential
bummer of all is entropy
I was really struck by this because
perhaps that's why when we're in love
we're also kind of sad there's a sadness
to the ecstasy you know beautiful things
sometimes can make us a little sad and
it's because what they hint that is the
exception a vision of something more a
vision of a hidden door a rabbit hole to
fall through but a temporary one and I
think ultimately that is kind of the
tragedy that is why I love
simultaneously fills us with melancholy
so that's why sometimes I feel nostalgic
over something I haven't lost yet
because I see its transience and so how
does one respond to this do we do we
love harder do we squeeze tighter or do
we embrace the Buddhist creed of no
attachment that we pretend not to care
than everything and everyone we know is
going to be taken away from us and I I
don't know if I can accept that I think
I'm more side with the Dylan Thomas
chord that says I will not go quietly
into that good night but instead rage
against the dying of the light
I think that we defy entropy and
impermanence with our films and our
poems I think we hold onto each other a
little harder and say I will not let go
I do not accept the ephemeral nature of
this moment I'm go
to extend it for ever or at least I'm
going to try
you